[Music]
so here we are we're with the new apple
watch this is the ultra version it's
honestly so impressive when i saw the
event i was kind of like oh man it looks
a little big it looks a little heavy
it's surprisingly very light it's
actually made of titanium and ceramic
they have additional speaker which is
actually pretty great because they have
this new feature when you press the
action button which there's a new button
right here which will allow you to set
different actions when you press it but
when you hold the action button it'll
actually let out a pretty high decibel
sounds if you are on a trail and you
need help this will allow you to be able
to alert the authorities it also of
course has our digital crown which is
much larger than the previous version it
also has a really cool night mode so
when you scroll the digital crown down
it'll turn into this nice night mode so
everything will turn red so it will be
very easy on your eyes and remove all of
the blue
light from that
thank you good to see you
so now with the apple watch ultra and
the series 8 they have temperature
sensor which is so incredible for not
only tracking your cycle but for
ovulation as a woman this is something
that is so exciting i've been using the
aura ring for the past
wow like over a year and because it has
the temperature sensing it has been so
accurate to predict periods so
everyone with a period high five to us
we're gonna now have more accurate
predictions which is so exciting another
thing that i think is cool is this
display is it's a flat display it's also
super resistant and the flat display
makes it so much easier to be able to
scroll and use so i feel like if you're
out in the middle of nowhere it's way
easier to press the buttons and stuff on
the display the other thing that's also
interesting which i um i don't think
i'll be testing out because i am not a
very good swimmer but this has a dive
mode so basically when you dive it'll
automatically detect that you're diving
and it'll give you the water temperature
it'll show you how far you're diving and
that's pretty awesome maybe i'll get
scuba certified because of the apple
watch ultra
i don't know it's a possibility i just
thought i would try them on just to see
how they look how they feel
so this is the ocean loop band
this is the trail band
the crazy thing is
where's that like they do look pretty
large but
it's light like it's not heavy feel and
i think this trail loop band probably
fits the best because it keeps it nice
and snug this i feel like is a little
bit loose on my arm
so i probably wouldn't go with this one
thankfully i don't really go in the
ocean so we won't need to worry about
that so it has 36 hours of battery life
which is pretty impressive especially
for a watch like this which makes sense
because it is much larger there's going
to be a new optimization that's coming
out in the fall and you'll be able to
actually get 60 hours which is kind of
cool because if you are out in the
middle of nowhere to be able to have
that added battery life is pretty
awesome this also has the precision dual
frequency gps which will be super
helpful because even when i'm downtown
it's really hard to sometimes get gps
signals so if you are out in the middle
of nowhere or you're doing a marathon or
something and you're running in areas
where you need precise location this
will definitely aid with that something
else really cool that they added in the
new ultra and the series 8 is crash
detection so if you unfortunately find
yourself in a car crash you'll be able
to alert authorities immediately to get
help and that's honestly something that
is so cool and during the event they
always show these apple watch stories
and they're so touching and it's so
incredible to see how this device has
helped so many people and it saved so
many lives i definitely think that this
is built for the action sports person in
mind but hey who's to say that the
everyday person can't enjoy the apple
watch ultra because i know i'm
definitely pre-ordering the apple watch
ultra is available for 7.99 and this was
just a first look of it here at the
apple event today thank you guys so much
for watching i will see you guys in my
next video like comment subscribe and i
have more apple videos coming very very
shortly if they're not out already check
them out here here or here bye
hey hello hello
how are you so nice to finally meet you
in fast i was like wait we've met him
like no actually we haven't looked in
peachy hey and i was like wait i just
saw you like a couple days ago did you
say hi to my vlog hey how you doing
it's me